what's going on guys this is rob and
this episode of what if right episode
number two was fantastic but before we
get into it i just want to say it was
good to hear chadwick boseman play
t'challa again right it was so great to
hear them and i know i can go back and
watch any of his appearances in the
marvel cinematic universe up to this
point but it's not the same right having
him play t'challa in a way that just
hasn't quite been done yet was cool and
it's so disappointing to know that
that's just never gonna happen again so
it's as amazing as it is it's very
bittersweet it's awesome that we got to
see chadwick boseman play t'challa and
we'll get to see him play to charla
three more times in the in the what if
series but it's also bitter because once
that's done that's it we're not aware of
him having recorded anything else with
regards to the mcu before his passing so
that'll basically be the end of it but
getting into our episode what if episode
two was fantastic and i feel like this
really highlights the potential of what
the what if episodes can be because
here's the thing looking back at episode
number one if i'm being honest with you
guys i did enjoy it but it was a what if
in its most pure sense right what if
peggy carter was captain america instead
of steve rogers and then basically
everything plays out the same with the
exception of the mini angled one that
came out at the very end of the episode
from that dimension presumably between
universes and that was it everything
else was essentially identical what we
had in episode two is really what makes
the what if series and mobile comics so
interesting the reality is that a lot of
the early what of comics that came out
of marvel were basically exactly like
the the first episode where it's pretty
straightforward right what if this one
thing happened differently and then
everything more or less plays out the
same with some slight deviations uh
episode number two is what the what if
series your marvel comics became as time
went on so here's a really good example
and there's it's not really a what if
comic but it kind of is right there's a
story that's written by a guy named
donnie cades called thanos wins and in
effect thanos shows up on earth kills
all the superheroes leaves and then
kills all the cosmic entities and all
the super powerful beings basically lays
waste and then conquers the entirety of
the universe all without using an
infinity gauntlet it's cool right so you
actually end up getting thanos from an
alternate reality that goes to the
future and then defeats his future
counterpart but it's kind of wild right
you have like like cosmic ghost rider
and like galactus who team up like
silver surfer is basically considered
the unworthy so the person who lifts
thor's hammer is kind of wild right i
mean i know it seems weird to be called
unworthy and being able to lift thor's
hammer but you know nonetheless it's a
cool concept right it was a really
really cool idea but that's kind of what
the what if series turned into as time
went on regardless this was cool because
what this did is it gave us not just an
answer to the question what if t'challa
had become star-lord but he gave us a
whole change of pace from everything
that we knew especially thanos right oh
my god the depiction of thanos was
absolutely fantastic i loved it right i
loved the way that thanos was shown here
and i feel like some of the more
hardcore people right some of the purest
if you want to call them that are kind
of like no thanos needs to be depicted
as like ultra serious and dead on the
inside and i kind of like no no i love
this right i love thanos with kind of a
slight comedic touch because the
alternate reality depictions of thanos
are really really interesting in marvel
comics more so than that one of the
things that i really liked is that when
the episode kicks off and you've got
t'challa who basically introduces
himself as star-lord like everybody
starts freaking out because he's
actually the person that peter quill
claimed to be in the first guardians of
the galaxy
when peter quill is like i'm the
legendary star-lord i did all this stuff
t'challa's actually done that i loved
the idea of the ravagers actually being
good guys i dig that right the fact of
the ravagers were people who basically
helped other individuals across the
galaxy right like robin hood is the
analogy they consistently use robbing
from the rich giving to the poor i loved
that it was a great concept seeing
nebula without all the modifications and
adjustments right as what you can get to
being her closest normal self minus the
machinery components that she has under
her eye that was cool right i mean i am
kind of sad we didn't really get to see
gamora and i'm kind of wondering where
her character was in the midst of all
this it's it's a it's a strange
situation right i mean i don't know if
the reason why we don't see her is the
result of the fact that she just doesn't
exist right she just was never born
thanos never showed up on her world and
took her which really stands to make the
most sense we know that thanos basically
showed up on gamora's world and then
adopted gamora because that was kind of
a part of his campaign of wiping out
half the life in the universe across
planet to planet until he got himself
until he got a hold of the infinity
gauntlet if that was never really a main
focus of his character there never would
have been a reason for him to show up on
gamora's homeworld lay waste to half his
population and then adopt her right so
it may just be gamora's just living on
her world and that's it right she grows
up to become whoever it is that she ends
up becoming and there's really nothing
more to it than that but one of the big
motivations that you guys saw in the
episode was the idea of stealing this
kind of energy away from the collector
and then using it to essentially
terraform barren worlds the funny thing
about that is that is a reference to the
council of reeds from jonathan hickman's
fantastic forum in jonathan hickman's
fantastic four one of the things you end
up learning is that in the multiverse
you have a council of reeds which is
basically a bunch of reed richards from
different universes all of whom have
come together to solve what they call
the problem of everything the biggest
issue is that all those versions of
reads basically abandon their families
right so like the rest of the fantastic
four they bailed on them to join the
council one of the things you end up
learning here is that as part of their
campaign of fixing everything it starts
at the bottom and works its way all the
way to the top so while they are
basically snatching up these alternate
reality versions of doctor doom and then
lobotomizing them and literally sticking
them in like this giant pit more or less
at the bottom of their citadel one of
the other things they done is they had
realized there are entire universes
where life simply hasn't evolved yet
right an infinite number of universes
means an infinite number of
possibilities and that's one of the
possibilities and so what they started
doing was turning those universes those
whole universes into essentially giant
farms where they would grow crops and
they would grab resources and they would
literally harvest everything they grew
in those universes and then they would
take them to other universes where
people just didn't have enough right
where worlds didn't have enough food or
didn't have enough uh water or whatever
it is they needed in order to survive so
instead of taking from some people in
that universe and giving it to others
they would just take from barren
universes and then just bring it to to
those universes right a lot of what you
saw in that at least the motivation
seems to be based off that now if i'm
being honest i don't think that really
has any significance i don't think it's
what if saying hey guys you're gonna see
the fantastic four because of this
reference this kind of ambiguous
reference to the fantastic four by
jonathan hickman which may or may not be
accurate i doubt that's the case
i just think it's a cool little easter
egg there right a cool little nod to
some of the work that's been done over
the course of marvel comics by some of
its most significant writers but one of
the other cool things that i liked here
i know this is a little bit a little bit
wonky here
i liked the depiction of the collector
here i think he was a little too comedic
a little more comedic than i would have
preferred but at the end of the day it's
still kind of interesting one of the
things that i've never really been a big
fan of in terms of how they've handled
the collector in the mcu is really
not displaying what he's capable of one
of the things to know the collector is
hugely powerful he is immensely powerful
technically the collector the grand
master the runner the champion who are
actually two characters you've never
seen in the mcu they're all part of a
loose knit brotherhood called the elders
of the universe in effect they're the
last surviving members of their own
respective races but they're billions of
years old they were considered ancient
when like earth was young right they've
just been around for so incredibly long
but the power that they've amassed
through different modifications and just
kind of enhancements and just the growth
of their physiology as time has gone on
has made them incredibly powerful i mean
they're not like equal to thanos with
like the infinity gauntlet powerful
right but they are very very powerful
and they've never really displayed that
with the collector the collector almost
kind of seems like just a guy who's just
really old and just been around for a
while and that's basically it but i
always wish they'd done a little bit
more with that regardless it was cool i
loved the little appearances of howard
the duck that was fun which i'm pretty
sure was voiced by by seth green i
always wish they'd done more with howard
the duck right how are the ducks one of
those weird wonky characters who just
never really made a whole lot of sense
in terms of why he existed in marvel
comics but we just kind of run with it
and just say yeah i mean it's out of the
dark right an anthropomorphic duck from
a reality where basically everything's
anthropomorphic animals and they more or
less exist like the way you expect
humans to and you just kind of go with
it
um i did love that i did love seeing
howard the duck here but again just
small little moments small little things
i love that at the end of the day the
guardians of the galaxy if you want to
call them that kind of this loose band
was basically the ravagers uh plus like
thanos and a couple other guys i liked
that and in all honesty and this is a
crazy thing if i'm being honest with you
guys i want to see more of that and i
think that's one of the things and
really the way the the whole episode
ended leaves it open for that and i
think that's one of the things that the
what if series is is really focusing on
is hey guys let's create a somewhat semi
open ending and then just kind of see
what happens so the way this episode
ended right with regards to the fact
that peter quill was never taken from
earth and instead it was t'challa that
peter quill is working at a dairy queen
but we know that he's still the son of
ego that was established at the
beginning of the episode and confirmed
at the end when ego played by kurt
russell actually shows up at the dairy
queen and basically says like you know
you got time for me that kind of thing
basically indicating like he's like i'm
gonna show you who you really are and
i'm gonna show you the kind of power
that you have and the words of the
watcher in the sense of like you know
this could lead to the destruction of
the universe leads to the idea that like
you could see a future episode or maybe
even some kind of a series unto itself
where you have this kind of reworked
version of the guardians of the galaxy
right so like t'challa and the ravagers
basically facing off against ego and
peter quill and then just kind of call
it a day right and maybe even the
infinity gauntlet will be brought in i
have no real idea but i think that's one
of the things that the what if series is
largely kind of focusing on here with
episode number one there wasn't really a
lot to go on right i guess we kind of
knew peggy carter would go on to become
a founding member of the avengers or at
least we could just assume that was the
case but with episode number two this
leaves a lot to to the imagination in
terms of what could come later on down
the line and that's what i'm really
hoping happens with the future of the
what if series i'm really hoping that we
have this situation where you have like
episodes that pop up and the the ending
is open enough to where we can see
something later but not so open that if
there really isn't a whole lot of
interest in it they just say yeah that's
where it is that's basically it done you
know and you can just imagine how you
how you think it would play out after
that and that's it right that's all that
really happened so again episode number
two was absolutely fantastic i loved the
episode it was beautifully done it was
great to see chadwick boseman return as
t'challa um one of the things that i was
kind of hoping for we didn't get it i
didn't think we would but one of the
things that i was kind of hoping for is
that as a little boy you would actually
see t'challa come in contact with a girl
with white hair in the african landscape
who of course would have been storm i'm
looking for any reason to bring the
x-men in the mcu i know a lot of you
guys are just like oh my god rob really
yes really i'm i'm looking for any
reason to bring the x-men in
right i mean we know from the comics
that like t'challa and storm had a
romantic interest when they were kids
and that they basically had to go their
separate ways because t'challa had to be
the king of wakanda right he had to kind
of undertake that role and the process
that a person needs to go through to
eventually become the king following his
fault you know following the the removal
of his father which ultimately resulted
in his father's death but nonetheless
right i would have loved to have seen
that i think it would have been a cool
little little easter egg or a cool
little moment cool little reference
right but regardless it was a great
episode i absolutely loved it i had a
great time watching it let me know what
you guys think down in the comments
right what'd you guys think about this
episode i thought it was beautiful but
with that being said guys we're gonna
bring this to an end thank you all for
watching and i will catch you all later
peace